[Music]
this morning we're talking about colon
cancer it's colon cancer awareness month
a disease that's a lot more common than
you may think Brazilian soccer Legend
Pele recently lost his battle with it as
have a long list of high-profile
celebrities including Chadwick Boseman
Audrey Hepburn and likely many people
that you might know as well Candace
Charles ruining is live in studio with
what you need to know to protect
yourself Candace good morning
good morning Heather good morning folks
thank you so much for bringing up all
those names it very much is true it
could be anyone that gets less important
for you to get screened I have Colleen
here with me these large inflatable
Cullen to give you an example of what
really your colon tissue should look
like this is your normal colon tissue
these are when polyps show up it's a
first sign of having colon cancer but
it's the only way that for you to get to
know if this is there is if you get
screened now you should start to get
screening by 45 unless you have someone
in your family who has it and I have a
Georgia from Nevada Cancer Association
as well tell me a little bit about the
screening and what other things people
should be doing prior to getting
screened yeah so screening will be at
age 45 like you mentioned getting a
colonoscopy there are different methods
like getting an at-home stool test so it
could be either a fit test or a cola
guard
um if in order to try to prevent uh
colonosc uh from getting colon cancer
there are different methods one is live
in a healthy lifestyle to try to avoid
processed foods and most important like
we keep mentioning get screened get
screened right and you'll be able to see
these if you get those screened early
because if not it could develop into man
polyps and then Crohn's disease and
later Advanced colorectal cancer now
right now you guys are all over the
state where can people find you guys
they can find us at all around the
community with their health events they
could found us here in the southern
Nevada or they found that in Northern
Nevada as well all around the community
perfect thank you so much so much for
all you guys doing the community we
really appreciate it you can find out
more about the Nevada cancer Coalition
on our website 8newsnow.com for now live
in the studio I'm Candace Charles 8 News
Now